[Music]
oh wow I'm a nostalgia critic guy
remember it so you don't have to you
know it must be hard being Jewish I mean
I don't want to make an assumption about
a pain a group of people I don't
represent us going through but it's
gotta be hard not because of the years
of oppression not because they're still
prejudiced jerk off husband but because
around the holidays for all the
well-known Christmas movies that exist
you only have one well-known Hanukkah
movie and sadly it's brought to you by
Beelzebub foreskin himself Adam Sandler
[Music]
[Applause]
yep we have Jimmy Stewart finding the
will to live again you have Adam Sandler
humping a car
we have Ebenezer Scrooge donating to the
cold and hungry you have deer eating
shit we have Charlie Brown realizing the
importance of loving thy neighbor you
have Rob Schneider playing a stereotype
so racist that Asians will be praying
for the good old days of Mickey Rooney
and squinty eyes and buck teeth I never
knew the hardships that your people had
to go through I never knew the turmoil
but that you had to get past yeah I
never do the pain that you were
suffering through until I realized that
this asshat is the cinematic face of
your beloved holiday I'm sorry I'm just
sorry it especially sucks cuz it comes
from a person who I think and be funny
and yet he constantly shits on the face
of good comedy Sandler can be
entertaining he's a good songwriter a
decent actor I can even make a funny
movie every once in a while but why does
he have to destroy the talents of good
artists clever performers and a
beautiful 2d animation departments so
desperate for a hint that they actually
thought the guy who bombed little Mickey
would be their salvation people I'm not
gonna lie this is a hard one no matter
what holiday you celebrate this is one
of the hardest movies you will ever have
to get through which is why I'm giving
you permission right now if you want to
go watch something else and leave me
here to review it I will completely
understand
[Music]
what do you say we dick the horse with
balls for tea or seeing how it's the
holidays you could sit and watch the
movie with me this is a crazy night oh
it's that kind of movie Oh Pete change
the title down tonight
so the film opens with a Rob Schneider
narration good start he tells us about
Davey played by Adam Sandler and how
everyone around Hanukkah time is happy
except for him which is ironic as during
most viewings of his movies and I'm
Sandler is the only happy one and
everybody else is miserable the head
honcho of holiday humbug lives right
here a little old dukesberry and that
fool is sitting inside the china dragon
coming up with his own way of feeling
tingly all over
Oh scorpion born at 5 minute that's God
the bill restaurant record and like I
said before that is Rob Schneider also
is the Chinese restaurant order I am the
realest thing Yamaguchi
he know pay for he's for scorpion born
that one caught me by surprise I
wouldn't make a joke about Rob Schneider
playing yet another racially insensitive
stereotype but I have a theory that the
more I believe Rob Schneider doesn't
exist the more possible it could be that
it might actually one day happen so
until further notice what Rob Schneider
racially insensitive stereotype I don't
see a Rob Schneider racially insensitive
stereotype hopefully not plan on driving
a nice stone oh no officer I'm just
gonna say good night to my car then walk
home and enjoy the holiday decorations
oh mama you like it when I hold you like
this cuz I'll do it all night long you
may notice too in this bill that the
animation is surprisingly really really
good
in fact it's insultingly good like what
the hell are these beautiful colors
excellent line work and graceful
movements doing in a story from the mind
of Hollywood's abandoned pregnancy it
wishes it have and ironically this works
against the film because the animation
is so good it doesn't match the tone at
all in a much better animated Sandler
film Hotel Transylvania the high-speed
energy and quick pace matches the
delivery perfectly here the animation is
much slower and closer to real life so
the characters don't move like funny
anime characters they move like
constipated baby elephants not being
allowed to express themselves the way an
anime character should in fact the real
fucking irony is there's no reason to
animate this story yeah when you watch
it all the way through it's pretty
pointless the budget probably will been
the same if not cheaper if it was
live-action so why do it was the idea
that they knew this shit wasn't gonna be
watchable in three dimensions so they
figure a drawing of the same shit would
somehow make it better if we mount a
Vinci drew a picture of kat dennings not
being funny and still be kat dennings
not being funny hyssop is it me what he
no pay for he sports goal being born oh
boy
so TV runs away from the police after
not paying his bill and gets arrested
but he's in good hands as thankfully the
judge like spewing exposition more than
he does actually sentencing people i've
sent you to reform school the drunk tank
the local psychiatric ward cuz you used
to be a good kid playing ball for the
jewish community center with the best
jump shot this town's ever seen what an
odd thing to say
i still got a pretty good jump shot let
me show you
i'd hit a three-pointer for you except
I'd have to drop my pants and pop a
thumb up my boo-boo Oh charming destined
to become a classic holiday live god
bless
maybe Christmas perhaps means a little
bit more I'd have to drop my pants and
pop a thumb up my booboo Dickens himself
could not write better just as he's
about to lay down some much welcome jail
time a man named whitey intervenes
whitey we went over this two months ago
it's your last year of refereeing the
youth league basketball
you're turning 70 years old and our
insurance company says they won't cover
you anymore Jesus guys you have any
lines not telling somebody else's
backstory whitey you're is hard to
figure out as the origin of my tie which
of course started to be worn in Europe
during the Thirty Years War what you
don't know the 30 Years War is well I'll
start from the beginning years ago the
earth was a molten mass whitey if you
want to work with this Punk than god
bless you but mr. stone
what whitey says go so whitey offers to
look after him as a referee in training
the performance of this white-haired
little man is voiced by well gee it
could be anyone Abby I don't have a clue
maybe Sandler her some angelic voice
thespian from the Shakespearean theatre
and said he must be one of my leading
stars I mean this is a character was in
what 70% of the movie thank God I found
a voice so charming and so beloved to
listen to that 70% of movie people 70%
of the movie you get to hear that voice
just listen to how not ear-bleeding ly
bad it is to listen to
[Music]
enjoy how he is in no way worse than Jar
Jar Binks singing Bjork while scratching
a blackboard with a screaming baby
during a fire alarm in a house of
howling mental patients in fact I'm not
gonna jump to any conclusions I'm just
gonna call mr. Sandler right now to
figure out who did that voice hello mr.
Sandler yeah nostalgia critic longtime
admirer of your genius uh listen I just
have one question for you
who was that inspired old man who put
trade why do you eat crazy nights yeah
actually I got a little secret for you
it wasn't an old man at all mr. Sammon I
think I speak for all the world when I
say that we as a species have seen
actors become other people but you sir
you have taken it to a whole new level
you are like some sort of mutant
chameleon that we could not see you to
become other things other entities thank
you severe oh and your choice to have
him in the majority of this film so that
we can hear your beautiful instruments I
just have to say thank you thank you for
behalf of all the world for letting us
be a part of this magical is very kind
of me the slug Mel Blanc the man of a
thousand voices the voice of all the
Looney Tunes fuck him
he is shit compared to your know if I
can find a way to get his body and put
little upside down crosses on into a
sure that he is rotting in hell because
he even attempted to be the best when he
knew that one point you would be bored
to bring us this whiny voice is it
insulting
to make sure that he suffers are even
trying to do something in the venue to
dig up the corpse of Mel Blanc so that
you could take your dick and shove it up
his ass because that is how little of a
candle he holds to you he holds to you
and your brilliance for whitey Brooke
hey praise a nice day an honor please
stop saying oh okay you're scaring me
and I gotta go
thank you so whitey shows in the ropes
as referee and also reveals that he's
hoping to win the patch award the
highest honor the town hands out but
that won't help much as Davie big shock
he's an asshole to everybody foul on
this kid for eating everything in sight
jelly jugs next time you come on my
court you better wear a bra okay you
know how with the Grinch you kind of
love to hate them well Adam Sandler
movies are worse than cancer
yeah I have no joke there it just feels
fucking good to say how much I hate Adam
Sandler movies good to see you still got
those circus beat man your children's
9:00 yeah really is incredible hearing
these two completely different voices
talk to each other isn't it
it's about as impressive as Christopher
Walken voicing all the characters I'm
Popeye oh well let's say you and I have
sex and stuff olive oil I also want to
bang you oh dear well I got a thing for
Elephant Man syndrome so I guess I'll
choose you me okay well I'm gonna do
this weird thing where I'm naked and
then suddenly I'm not blue you just
never know it was him the whole time so
whitey feels a good way to get his
attitude up is to take him to the mall
so what's good about this place product
placement no I'm not even kidding
we love our sponsors do us like backdoor
whores look at some of these body shop
Iraq GNC RadioShack Bethlehem or a
catapult
Spencer's kids for some faith go boo sip
battles don't think doughnuts too simply
the best and don't forget the orange
chicken and Panda Express oh my god
baby I'm so sorry
I mean I thought your product placement
was the worst but after seeing this
you're gonna be subtle I'm gonna suffer
through the rest of this so what's the
only thing worth and listening to
Whitey's doornail in your brain
please how about if he sings with that
doornail in your brain voice
[Music]
and there were my eardrums I sure be sad
but I'm just happy I don't to listen to
Adam Sandler anymore now the great irony
to hell obnoxious Whitey's voices that
Sandler does another voice as Whitey's
sister who lives with him and
surprisingly is not that bad what could
this be the character he interacts with
I mean she's annoying but she's much
less annoying and actually sounds like a
different person at least why didn't
they just go with her well maybe because
she wouldn't be nearly as funny being be
lessly shut down the port-a-potty and
climbing out covered in poo no that's
right this is a Happy Madison honors
where something that they see come out
then everyday is suddenly hilarious
because it reminds them of something
that was scandalous when they were 2
years old misunderstanding ball players
names and standing positions oh no they
have to think for that we don't want
something smart here this is a Happy
Madison audience oh no the crawling
intelligence show another probe see show
another protein look the dear smiley one
probe it is tea now give them your money
they work for seconds to think of this
awe-inspiring
it's feeding time
who wants White Castle Snyder first now
it's funny cuz they shouldn't live you
know for a movie obviously trying to
make Adam Sandler's character look like
Adam Sandler I don't think that's what
he looks like with his shirt off
can we get visual confirmation on that
there we go
slight artistic liberties so of course
they win and the guy eats a jockstrap
so as Davey and Jennifer drive
themselves home there actually is a nice
song about how Jessica and Davey used to
be young and well have a decent
childhood over there's my family home
[Applause]
[Music]
but yes whose voice constantly ruins it
for my warm heart fuck me
Cali even golem with his annoying voice
would be like trust battle you're
chilling but jockstrap guy gets his
revenge later by bringing down Davey's
house ain't little of you buffoons you
meet between freezing to death outside
and listening to your voice let it snow
let it snow let it snow here's the you
guys for letting me crash let's see
we've literally just gone three minutes
how about another testicle stabbing
sauce yeah I'm sure this is one of those
songs that Sandler just couldn't fit
under one of his albums so might as well
waste about a dozen Korean animators on
it oh my god that's so much better
hi I can just look at the beautiful
animation and not listen to dialogue
from riders that were juggled as babies
in fact I can just imagine my own story
to make this one even better hey awesome
Klaus what did you do today I made
Christmas a whole lot more awesome this
year really and how did you do that
well I kick Ron Howard in the balls for
making the Grinch shot at every greedy
fuck ass went shopping on Thanksgiving
night and produced eight Hanukkah movies
that were actually funny to people who
can count past the number four Wow
I think my balls just grew while talking
to you it's all part of spending
millions of dollars to animate something
that actually makes an impact on
somebody's life
hi I'm awesome Klaus
the only thing I can't work around is
the shitting a moment of silence for the
happy medicine audience
[Applause]
[Music]
you
so here's a fun question what's even
more pathetic than having your cast full
of unfunny and unlikable characters
having a serious death scene acted out
by a cast of unfunny and unlikable
characters yeah uh-huh they go that
route they actually give Davy a
backstory involving his parents dying in
a car accident and of course this is the
reason he's such a jerk to everyone yeah
because the movie was shit-eating dear
three-breasted women and an extreme
close-up on harry white asses clearly
you can segue so easily it's a heavy
drama like this why don't you just have
Chris Tucker deliver the bad news while
you're at it oh my god your parents are
dead one minute they find their bone
gone they bloat up going to fiery
inferno yeah eight Kentucky Fried
parents crispy extra fried oh my god
they gon go forever like me a rush hour
boat it's something didn't make it cause
jack is like a bajillion years old now
he can still kick my ass oh my god your
parents are dead basically shut down I
don't know what to say there's nothing
to say my parents are dead Happy
Hanukkah
ah yes and Elinor's Christ nor they
makes the scene even more powerful Jesus
fuck what do they do for an encore read
the Diary of Anne Frank this of course
puts Davy in a bad mood again and causes
him to rebel did you read anything about
a deform referee who spends 35 years
trying to win some stupid patch so he
can pretend people actually like him
they have an award for the freakiest
looking for turtle twins who no one even
gives a crap about you two are
definitely winning and you're a ball oh
good your house sucks and you know just
as a testament to how fucking bad this
movie really is even with the backstory
that his parents were killed when he was
young they still make him too unlikable
to sympathize with even the Grinch
narrator would be like I'd give him the
choice between the two of you I choose
the hell no I'm going with the green guy
or at least he didn't make jack until
the odds movie washes
Wow just when you started to really like
Davi was that what we were supposed to
be doing he goes and has a fun whole
relapse well as you heard it put so
eloquently he breaks into a mall going
on another rampage whoa
does this mean we possibly get even more
product placements oh why don't we just
have the private placements come to life
and save the day everybody wake up this
is not a rehearsal all right I got it oh
hey critic where you going
well the movies horde itself out to
everybody might as well see what it's
like
how was it empty hollow not over nearly
fast enough I could have told you that
so thanks to the biggest cinematic
corporate orgy since food fight Davi
opens up and finally cries over the loss
of his parents this doesn't mean much
though as some cops bust him for
breaking and entering
save your sorries for the judge but
thankfully Sally's super athletic body
also has lightning-fast reflexes and he
outwits the cups nothing takes down the
double chin with the Jacob style abs
both they find out at the banquet that
night that whitey didn't win the
petulant
[Applause]
[Music]
oh what a shame he was such a nice guy
too I mean this is the man who so
selflessly left after his award he
didn't win was announced this award was
for humbleness right but it's okay
because Devi has another annoying song
to say except for that part where you
said you weren't welcomed into his house
anymore
but why bring any part of brain activity
into this movie now this inspires the
crowd who we established a moment ago
only has a few Jewish people in it the
randomly do a Jewish dance
[Music]
if this world so everybody meets up with
whitey at the mall they hand them the
award and at the moment is so touching
that even Davies hallucinations start
crying seriously is he imagining that or
what any chance we can end with the most
annoying sound in the world thanks the
credits start to roll and I'm blown out
of my ass to discover that four people
wrote this piece of shit four people oh
fuck do you think that process worked
movies movies movies Hey
people may die but stupidity is forever
this is not only one of the worst
holiday specials ever made this is one
of the worst movies I've ever seen
period I cannot believe how unfunny it
is Santa's voice acting is probably the
worst I've ever heard in my life and the
movie couldn't even keep its
mean-spirited tone in a strange way I
could at least have a touch of respect
if it was meant to be unlikable from
beginning to end but no they fit in this
emotional bullshit that they actually
think is gonna make you feel that
special holiday feeling seriously guys
after
the only holiday feeling I got from this
is similar to when I puke from drinking
too much eggnog and every time I see
this incredible animation matched up
with it it makes me want to punch those
fucking idiots that keep happy medicine
popular when better talent could be
utilized for better stories fuck this
movie and to all the Jewish people who
are saddened that this is the only
well-known Chanukah movie I apologize
for all of you to make up for it here's
a picture of Hitler roasting out of it
and now here's one with that obses that
one wasn't for you that was definitely
for me I'm the Nostalgia Critic and I
have just seen the absolute worst
holiday special I have ever witnessed in
my entire life
[Music]
Wow